turns out you were right i'm gonna ask
you about free will
oh okay uh you've recently released an
episode
of your podcast making sense for those
with a shorter attention span
uh basically summarizing your position
on free will i think it was
under an hour and a half yeah yeah
that's is
is brief and clear uh so allow me to
summarize the summary
tlgr and uh maybe you tell me where i'm
wrong
so free will is an illusion and
even the experience of free will is an
illusion like we don't even
experience it what am
i am i good in my summary yeah
this is a this is a line that's a little
hard to
scan for people i i say that it's not
merely that free will
is an illusion the illusion of free will
is an illusion
right like there is no illusion of free
will and that is a
unlike many other illusions uh
that's a a more
fundamental claim it's like it's not
that it's wrong it's it's not even wrong
i mean that's i guess
that was uh i think wolfgang paulie who
derided one of his uh
colleagues or enemies with that uh um
aspersion about his theory in quantum
mechanics um
it's so there are things that you there
there are genuine illusions there are
things that
you do experience and then you can
kind of punch through that experience or
you can't you can't actually experience
you can't you can't experience them any
other way it's just
um it's we just know it's not a vertical
experience just take like a visual
illusion there are visual illusions that
you know
a lot of these come to me on twitter
these days there's these amazing visual
illusions
where like you know that every figure in
this
gif seems to be moving but nothing in
fact is moving you can just like put a
ruler on your screen and nothing's
moving
um some of those illusions you can't see
any other way and they're just
they're hacking aspects of the visual
system that
are just eminently hackable and you you
know you you have to use a ruler
to to convince yourself that the thing
isn't actually moving
now there are other visual illusions
where you're taken in by it at first
but if you pay more attention you can
actually see that it's not there
right or it's not how it first seemed
like the uh like the necker cube is a
good example of that like the necker
cube is just that
schematic of a cube of a transparent
cube which pops out one way or the other
the one one face can pop out and the
other face can pop
out but you can actually just see it as
flat with no pop out
which is a more vertical way of looking
at it
so there are subject there are kind of
inward correlates to this
and i would say that the um
[Music]
the sense of self a sense of self and
free will are closely related i often
describe them as
as two sides of the same coin but
they're not quite the same
in the their their spuriousness i mean
so the sense of self is something that
people i think do experience right it's
not a very
clear experience but it's not
i wouldn't call the illusion of self an
illusion but the illusion of free will
is an illusion in that as you pay more
attention to your experience
you begin to see that it's totally
compatible
with an absence of free will you don't i
mean coming to back to the place we
started
you don't know what you're going to
think next you don't know what you're
going to intend next
you don't know what's going to just
occur to you
that you must do next you don't know you
don't know how much you're going to feel
the behavioral imperative to act on that
thought
if you suddenly feel oh i don't need to
do that that's
i can do that tomorrow you don't know
where that comes from you didn't know
that was going to arise you didn't know
that was going to be compelling
all of this is compatible with some evil
genius in the next room just typing in
code into your experience just like this
okay let's give him the
uh oh my god i just forgot it was gonna
be our anniversary in one week
thought right give him the cascade of
fear
uh give him give him this brilliant idea
for the thing he can buy that's gonna
take him no time at all in this this you
know overpowering sense of relief
all of our experiences is compatible
with with the
the script already being written right
it's and i'm not saying the script is
written i'm not saying that
fatalism is you know is um the right way
to look at this
but we just don't have even our most
deliberate voluntary action where we go
back and forth
between two options you know thinking
about the reason for a
and then then reconsidering and going
thinking harder about b and just going
eenie meenie miney mo
until the end of the hour however
laborious you can make it
there is a utter mystery at your back
finally promoting the thought or
intention
or ration rationale
that is most compelling and therefore
deliberate
behaviorally
effective uh and
just this and this can drive some people
a little crazy so i i usually preface
what i say about free will with the
caveat that if if thinking about
your mind this way makes you feel
terrible well then
stop you know get you get off the ride
you know switch the channel you don't
have to go down this path
but for me and for for many other people
it's incredibly freeing
just to recognize this about the mind
because
one it re one you realize that you're
it's a
cutting through the illusion of the of
the self is immensely freeing for a lot
of reasons that
that we can talk about separately but
losing the sense of free will
does two things very vividly for me one
is it totally undercuts
the basis for the psychological basis
for hatred because when you
when you think about the experience of
hating other people
what that is anchored to is a feeling
that they
really are the true authors of their
actions i mean that someone is doing
something that you find so
despicable right let's say they're you
know targeting you
unfairly right they're maligning you on
twitter
or they're you know they're suing you or
they're doing something
they broke your car window they did
something awful and now you have a
grievance against them
and you're relating to them very
differently emotionally in your own mind
than you would if a force of nature had
done this right or if it's if it had
just been you know a virus or if it had
been a wild animal or a malfunctioning
machine right like to those things you
don't attribute any kind of freedom of
will
and while you you may suffer the
consequences of
catching a virus or being attacked by a
wild animal or having a you know your
car break down or whatever it may
frustrate you you don't slip into this
mode of
hating the agent in a way that
completely commandeers your your
mind and deranges your life i mean you
just don't i mean there are people who
spend
decades hating other people for
what they did and it's it's just pure
poison
it's a useful shortcut to compassion and
empathy yeah
but the question is say that this call
what was it the horse of consciousness
let's call it the uh
the consciousness generator black box
that we don't understand
and is it possible that the script
that we're walking along
that we're playing that's already
written is
actually being written in real time it's
almost like you're driving down a road
and in real time that road is being laid
down you know and this black box of
consciousness that we don't understand
is the place where this script is being
generated
so it's not it is being generated it
didn't always exist
so there's something we don't understand
that's fundamental about the nature of
reality
that generates both consciousness let's
call it maybe
the self i don't know if you want to
distinguish between those
yeah i definitely would yeah you would
because there's a bunch of illusions
we're referring to there's the illusion
of free will
there's the illusion of self and there's
the illusion of consciousness
you're saying i think you said there's
no
you're not as willing to say there's an
illusion of consciousness
in fact i would say it's impossible
impossible you're a little bit more
willing to say that there's
an illusion of self and you're
definitely saying there's an illusion of
free will
yes yes and i'm definitely saying
there's an illusion
that a certain kind of self is an
illusion not every we
mean many different things by this
notion of self so maybe
i should just differentiate these things
so consciousness can't be an illusion
because any illusion
proves its reality as much as any other
vertical
perception i mean if you're
hallucinating now that's just as much of
a demonstration of consciousness
as really seeing what's quote actually
there if you're if you're dreaming and
you don't know it
you that is consciousness right if
you're you can be confused about
literally everything
you can't be confused about
the the underlying
claim you know whether you make it
linguistically or not
but just the the the the cognitive
uh assertion that something
seems to be happening it's the seeming
that is is the cash value of
consciousness
can i take a tiny tangent okay so what
if
i am creating consciousness in my mind
to convince you that i'm human so it's a
useful
social tool not a fundamental
property of experience like
of being a living thing what if it's
just like a social tool
to to almost like a useful computational
trick
to place myself into reality
as we together communicate about this
reality
and another way to ask that because you
said it much earlier
you talk negatively about robots as you
often do so let me
because um you'll probably die first
when they take over yeah yeah um
no no i'm looking forward to certain
kind of robots i mean i i'm not
if we can get this right this would be
amazing but you don't like the robots
that fake consciousness that's what you
you don't like the idea of fake it till
you make it well no i
it's not that i don't like it it's that
i'm worried
that we will lose sight of the problem
and the problem has massive
ethical consequences i mean if we if we
create robots that
really can suffer that would be a bad
thing
right and if if we really are committing
a murder
when we recycle them that would be a bad
thing that's how i know you're not
russian why is it a bad thing that would
create robots that can suffer
isn't suffering a fundamental thing from
which like beauty springs
like without suffering do you really
think we would have beautiful things in
this world
okay well that's a that's a tangent on a
tangent okay we'll go there i would love
to go there but let's not go there just
yet all right
but you know i do think it would be if
anything is bad creating hell
and populating it with real
minds that really can suffer in that
hell that's you know
that's bad you know that's the the you
are you are worse than
than any mass murderer we can name if
you created i mean
this could be in robot form or you know
more likely it would be in
in some similar simulation of a world
where we managed to populate it with
conscious mind so that we know whether
we knew they were conscious or not
and that world is is a state of you know
that's it's unendurable
um that would just it just taking the
thesis seriously that
there's nothing that mind
intelligence and consciousness
ultimately are substrate independent
right it doesn't you don't need a
biological brain to be conscious you
certainly don't need a biological brain
to be intelligent
right so if we just imagine that
consciousness at some point comes along
for the ride as you scale up into in
intelligence
well then we could find ourselves
creating conscious minds
that are miserable right and that's just
like creating a person who's
miserable right it could be worse than
creating a person who's miserable could
be
even more sensitive to suffering cloning
them and maybe for entertainment
watching them suffer
just like watching a person for suffer
for entertainment
you know so but but back to your the
your primary question here which is
differentiating
differentiating consciousness and self
and free will as concepts and kind of
degrees of illusoriness
the problem with free will is that
what most people mean by it and that the
you know and dan this is where dan
dennett is going to get off the ride
here right so like he he doesn't
he's going to disagree with me that i
that i know what most people mean by it
but
i have a very uh keen sense having
talked about this
topic for many many years and
seeing people get wrapped around the
axle of it and seeing
seeing in myself what it's like to have
felt
that i was a self that had free will and
then to no longer feel that way right to
know what it's like to actually disabuse
myself of that
sense cognitively and emotionally
and to recognize what's left what goes
away and what doesn't go away
on the basis of that epiphany i have a
sense that i know
what people think they have in hand when
they worry about whether free will
exists and it is
the it is the flip side of this feeling
of self it's the flip side of
feeling like you are not merely
identical
to experience you feel like you're
having an experience you feel like
you're an agent that is appropriating an
experience there's a protagonist
in the movie of your life and it is you
it's not just the movie right it's like
the the
every like their sights and sounds and
sensations and thoughts and emotions and
this whole cacophony of experience a
felt experience a felt experience of
embodiment
but there seems to be a
a rider on the horse or a passenger in
the body
right people don't feel truly identical
to their bodies down to their toes
they sort of feel like they have bodies
they feel like they're minds
in bodies and that feels like
a self that feels like me and
again this gets very paradoxical when
you talk about
the experience of of being in
relationship to yourself or talking to
yourself you know giving yourself a pep
talk i mean if you're the one talking
why are you also the one listening like
why do you need the pep talk and why
does it work if you're the one giving
the pep talk right yeah
or like or if i said like where are my
keys right if i'm looking for my keys
why do i think the superfluous thought
where are my keys i know i'm looking for
the keys i'm the one looking
who am i telling that you know that we
now need to look for the keys right
so that duality is weird but leave that
aside
there's the sense so
and this this becomes very vivid when
people try to
learn to meditate you know most people
they start by
they start they close their eyes and
they're told to pay attention to an
object like the breath
say so you close your eyes and you pay
attention to the breath
and you can feel it at the tip of your
nose or the rising falling of your
abdomen
and you're you're paying attention and
you feel something vague there
and then you think i thought why the
breath why am i
why am i paying attention to the breath
what's what's so special about the
breath
and then you then you then you notice
you're thinking and you're not paying
attention to the breath anymore and then
you
then you realize okay the practice is
okay i should notice thoughts and then i
should come back to the breath
but this starting point is the
of the conventional starting point of
feeling like you are an agent very
likely in your head
a locus of consciousness a locus of
attention that
can strategically pay attention to
certain parts of experience like i can
focus on the breath
and then i get lost in thought and now i
can come back to the breath
and i can open my eyes and i can i'm
over here behind my face
looking out at a world that's other than
me and there's this kind of subject
object perception and that is the
default
starting point of selfhood of
subjectivity
and married to that is the sense that
i can decide what to do next
right i am i am an agent who can pay
attention to the cup
i can listen to sounds there are certain
things that i can't control
certain things are happening to me and i
just can't control them so for instance
that if someone asks well can you not
hear
a sound right like don't hear the next
sound don't hear anything for a second
or don't hear
don't hear i'm you know i'm snapping my
fingers don't hear this where's your
free will you know
like just stop this from coming in you
you you realize okay wait a minute
my my my abundant freedom does not
extend
to something as simple as just being
able to pay attention to something else
than this okay well so that i'm not that
kind of free agent but
at least i can decide what i'm going to
do next and i'm going to
i'm going to pick i'm going to pick up
this water right
and there's a feeling of identification
with the impulse with the intention with
the thought that occurs to you with the
with the feeling of speaking like you
know what am i what am i going to say
next well i'm saying it so here here
goes
this is me i it feels like i'm the
thinker i'm the i'm
the one who's in control but
all of that is born of not really paying
close attention
to what it's like to be you and and so
this is
this is where meditation comes in or
this is where um
again you can get you can get at this
conceptually
you can unravel the notion of free will
just by by
thinking certain certain thoughts but
you can't
feel that it doesn't exist unless you
can pay
close attention to how thoughts and
intentions arise so
the way to unravel it conceptually is
just to realize okay
i didn't make myself i didn't make my
genes i didn't make my brain i didn't
make the
the environmental influences that
impinged upon this system for the last
54 years
that have produced my brain in precisely
the state
it's in right now such and with all of
the the receptor weightings and
densities
and you know it's just i'm i'm exactly
the machine i am right now through
no fault of of
my own as the experience in itself i get
no credit and i get no blame
for the genetics and the enviro the
environmental influences here
and yet those are the only things that
could
contrive to
to produce my next thought or
impulse or or moment of behavior and if
you were going to add something magical
to that
clockwork like an immortal soul
you can also notice that you didn't
produce your soul really you you can't
account for the fact that you don't have
the soul
of someone who doesn't like any of the
things you like
or wasn't interested in any of the
things you were interested in or you
know or
was a psychopath or was either you had
an iq of 40 or like there's like there's
nothing
nothing about that that the person who
believes in us
in a soul can claim to have controlled
and yet that is
also totally dispositive of whatever
happens next
and but everything you've described now
maybe you can correct me but it kind of
speaks to the materialistic nature of
the hardware
but even if you add magical ectoplasm
software
you didn't you didn't produce that
either i i know but
if we can think about the actual
computation running on the hardware
and running on the software there's
something you said recently which you
think of uh
culture as an operating system so if we
just
remove ourselves a little bit from the
conception of
human civilization being a collection of
humans
and rather us just being a distributed
uh computation system on which there's
some kind of operating system running
and then the computation that's running
is the actual thing that generates
the interactions the communications and
maybe even free will the experiences of
all those free will
do you ever think of do you ever try to
reframe the world in that way where
it's like ideas are just using us
thoughts are using individual nodes
in the system and they're just jumping
around and they also have
ability to generate like experiences so
that we can push those ideas along
and basically the main organisms here
are the thoughts
not the humans yeah but then that
erodes the boundary between self and
world right so so then there's no self
really a really integrated self to have
any kind of will
at all like if you're just a meme plex
i mean if there's just like if if you're
just a collection of memes
yeah and i mean like we're all kind of
like like currents
like eddie's in in in this river of of
ideas
right so it's like um
and it seems to have structure but
there's no real boundary between that
part of the flow of water
and the rest i mean if our and i would
say that much of our mind
answers to this kind of description i
mean so much of our mind
has been it's obviously not
self-generated and it's not it's
not going to find it by looking in the
brain it's it it is the result
of culture largely but also
um uh
[Music]
you know it's it's the genes on one side
and culture on the other
m meeting to allow for
manifestations of mind that don't that
aren't actually bounded by
the the person in any clear sense it was
just the example
i often use here but there are so many
others is just
the fact that we're following the rules
of english grammar
to whatever degree we are it's not that
we certainly haven't consciously
represented these
rules for ourself we haven't invented
these rules
we haven't i mean that there are there
are norms of
language use that we couldn't even
specify because we haven't you know
we're not grammarians we're not we
haven't studied this
we don't even have the right concepts
and yet we're following these rules and
we're noticing
you know we're noticing as you know an
error when we fail to follow
these rules um and virtually every other
cultural norm
is like that i mean these are not things
we've invented you can you can
consciously decide to
to scrutinize them and override them but
i mean just think of just think of any
social situation where you're with other
people
and you're behaving in ways that are
culturally
appropriate right you're not being you
know you're not being
wild animals together you're following
you have some expectation of
how you shake a person's hand and how
you
um deal with with implements on a table
how you have a meal together
obviously this can change from culture
to culture and
and people can be shocked by how
different those things are right we you
know
we all have foods we find disgusting but
in some
countries dog is not one of those foods
right and and yet you know you and i
presumably would be
horrified to be served dog
those are not norms that we're
they are outside of us in some way and
they're
yet they're they're felt very viscerally
i mean they're
certainly felt in their violation you
know if you're if you are
just imagine you're you're in somebody's
home
you're eating something that tastes
great to you and you happen to be in
vietnam or wherever you know you you
didn't realize dog was potentially on
the menu
and you find out that you've just eaten
10 bites of what is uh you know really a
cocker spaniel
and you feel this
instantaneous urge to vomit right based
on an idea
right like so like you did not you're
not the author
of that norm that get
gave you such a powerful experience of
its violation
and i'm sure we can trace the moment in
your history
you know vaguely where it sort of got in
i mean very early on as kids you you
realize you're
you're treating dogs as pets and not as
food or as potential food
but yeah no it's but the point you just
made
opens us to like we are totally
permeable
to a sea of mind
yeah but if we take the metaphor of the
distributed computing systems
each individual node is
is part of performing a much larger
computation
but nevertheless is in charge of doing
the scheduling
of uh so assuming it's linux is doing
the scheduling of processes and it's
constantly alternating them that node is
making those
uh choices that note sure as hell
believes it has free will
and uh actually has free will because
it's making those hard choices
but the choices ultimately are part of
much larger computation that it can't
control
isn't it possible for that node to still
be that human node
uh is still making the choice well
it is so i'm not saying that your body
isn't doing really doing things right
and
some of those things can be
conventionally thought of as choices
right so it's like i can i can choose to
reach and
it's like it's not being imposed on me
that would be a different experience
like so there's a
there's an experience of of all you know
there's definitely a difference between
voluntary and involuntary action
there's uh so we that has to get
conserved by any account of the mind
that
jettisons free will you still have to
admit that that there's a difference
between
a tremor that i can't control
and a a purposeful motor action that i
can control and i can initiate on demand
and it's associated with intentions
uh and i've it's got efferent
you know motor copy which which is being
which is being predictive so that i can
notice errors you know i have
expectations when i reach for this if my
hand were actually to pass through the
bottle because it's a hologram
i would be surprised right so that shows
that i have a expectation of just
what my grasping behavior is going to be
like even before it happens
whereas with a tremor you don't have the
same kind of thing going on
that's a distinction we have to make so
i am yes i'm
really the proxy my intention
to move subject which is in fact can be
subjectively felt
really is the proximate cause of my
moving it's not coming from elsewhere in
the universe
i'm not saying that so in that sense the
node is really deciding
to execute you know the the subroutine
now but um
that's not the feeling
that has given rise to this this
conundrum
of free will right so the the people
feel like
people feel like they the crucial things
that people feel like they could have
done otherwise
right that's the that's the thing that
says when you when you run
back the clock of your life right you
run back the movie of your life
you flip back the few pages in the novel
of your life
they feel that at that at this point
they could behave differently than they
did right so like i
like but but given you know even given
your distributed computing example
it's either a determining fully
deterministic system or it's a deter
deterministic system that admits of some
random
you know influence in either case
um that's not the free will people think
they have the p
the free will people think they have is
damn i shouldn't have done that i i just
like i i shouldn't have done that
i could have done otherwise right i
should have done otherwise right like if
i
like if you think about something that
you deeply regret doing
right or that you do you hold someone
else responsible for
because they really are the upstream
agent in your mind of what they did
you know that's an awful thing that that
person did and they shouldn't have done
it
there is this illusion and it has to be
an illusion because there's there's
no picture of causation that would make
sense of it
there's this illusion that that if you
arrange the universe exactly the way it
was a moment ago
it could have played out differently and
the only way it could have played out
differently
is if there's randomness added to that
but
randomness isn't what people feel would
give them free will
right if you tell me that you know i
only reach for the water bottle this
time
because somebody's because there's a
random number generator in there
kicking off values and it finally moved
my hand
that's not the feeling of authorship
that's still not
control you're still not making that
decision
there's actually i don't know if you're
familiar with cellular automata
it's a really nice visualization of how
simple rules can create
incredible complexity that it's like
really dumb initial conditions to set
simple rules applied
and eventually you watch this thing and
if
the rule if the initial conditions are
correct you're going to
have emerge something that to our
perception system looks like
organisms interacting you can construct
any kinds of worlds and they're not
actually interacting
it's not they're not actually even
organisms and they certainly don't
aren't making decisions so there's like
systems you can create
that illustrate this point the question
is
whether there could be some room for
that's used in the 21st century the term
magic
back to the black box of consciousness
let me ask you
it this way if you're wrong about your
intuition about free will
what and somebody comes along to you and
proves
to you that you didn't you didn't have
the full picture
what would that proof look like what
would uh well that's that's the problem
that's why it's not
even an illusion in my world because
it's for me it's impossible to say
what the universe would have to be like
for free will to be a thing
right it's just it doesn't conceptually
map onto any
notion of causation we have and
that's unlike any other spurious claim
you might make so like
if you're gonna if you're gonna believe
in ghosts right
i understand what that claim could be
or like i i you know i don't happen to
believe in ghosts but
if it's it's not hard for me to specify
what would have to be true for ghosts to
be real
and so it is with a thousand other
things like ghosts right so like
okay so you're telling me that when
people die there's some part of them
that is not reducible at all to their
biology that lifts off them
and goes elsewhere and is actually the
kind of thing they can linger in closets
and in cupboards and
and actually it's immaterial but by some
principle of physics we don't totally
understand
it can make sounds and knock you know
objects
and even occasionally show up so they
can be visually beheld
um and it's just it seems like a miracle
but it's just this is just
some spooky noun in the universe that we
don't understand
let's call it a ghost that's fine i can
talk about that all day that the reasons
to believe in it the reasons not to
believe in it the way we would
scientifically test for it what would
have to be provable
so as to convince me that ghosts are
real
free will isn't like that at all there's
no description
of any concatenation of causes that
precedes
my conscious experience that sounds like
what people think they have
when they think they could have done
otherwise and that they really that they
the conscious agent
is really in charge right like if you
don't know what you're going to think
next
right and you can't help but think it
take those two premises on board
you don't know what it's going to be you
can't stop it
from coming and until you actually
know how to meditate you can't stop
yourself from
fully living out its behavioral or
emotional consequences
right like you have no you once you
mindfulness you know
arguably gives you a another degree of
freedom here
it doesn't give you free will but it
gives you some other game to play with
respect to
the the the emotional and behavioral
imperatives of thoughts
but short of ev
short of that i mean the reason why
mindfulness doesn't give you free will
is because you can't
you know you can't account for why in
one moment mindfulness arises right
and and in other moments it doesn't
right but
um but a pro a different process is
initiated once you
can can uh practice in that way well
if i could push back for a second by the
way i just had this thought bubble come
popping up all the time of just
two recent chimps arguing about the
nature of consciousness
it's kind of hilarious so on that thread
right you know
if we're even before einstein let's say
before einstein we were to conceive
about traveling
from point a to point b
say some point in the future we are able
to realize through engineering
a way which is suppose is consistent
with einstein's theory that you can have
wormholes you can travel from one point
to another
faster than the speed of light
and that would i think completely change
our conception what it means to travel
in the physical space and that
like completely transform our ability
you talk about causality but here let's
just focus on
what it means to travel through physical
space don't you think it's
possible that there will be inventions
or leaps in understanding about reality
that will allow us to see free will as
actually like us
humans somehow may be linked to this
idea of consciousness
are actually able to be authors of our
actions
it is a it's a non-starter for me
conceptually
it's a little bit like saying
could there be some breakthrough that
will cause us to realize that
circles are really square or the circles
are not really round
right no a circle is what we mean
by a perfectly round form right like
it's it's it's it
it's not it's not on the table to be
revised and
so i would say the same thing about
consciousness so it's just like saying
is there some breakthrough that would
get us to realize that consciousness
is really an illusion i'm saying no
because
what the experience of an illusion is as
much a demonstration of what i'm calling
consciousness as anything else right
like that that is consciousness um with
free will
it's a similar problem it's like um
again it comes down to a picture of
causality and there's just there's no
there's no other picture on offer and
what's more
i know i know what it's like on the
experiential side
to lose the thing to which it is
clearly anchored right like the feel
like it doesn't
feel and this is and this is the
question that almost nobody has people
who are debating me on on
the topic of free will i i'm
you know at 15 minute intervals i'm
making a claim
that i don't feel this thing and they
are
never become interested in well what's
that like
like okay you're actually saying you
don't you this
this thing isn't you know it isn't true
for you empirically it's not just
because
most people who who don't believe in
free will
philosophically also believe that we're
condemned to experience it like they
you just you can't live without this
feeling so
so you're actually saying you're able to
experience
the absence of
the illusion of free will yes yes for
are we talking about
whenever whenever two minutes at a time
or
um is this to require a lot of work and
meditation
are you literally able to load that into
your mind
and like play that right now right now
just in this conversation
so it's not it's not absolutely
continuous
but it's whenever i pay attention it's
like it's
the same and i would say the same thing
for the the illusoriness of the self in
the sen and again
we haven't talked about this so can you
still have the self and not have the
free will your mind
at the same time do they go at the same
time this is the same yeah it's the same
thing that they're always holding hands
when they walk out the door i mean
there really are two sides of the same
coin okay but it's it's just it comes
down to what it's like
to try to get to the end of this
sentence or what it's like to to finally
decide that
it's been long enough and now i need
another sip of water right if i'm paying
attention now if i'm not paying
attention
i'm probably i'm captured by some other
thought and that
feels a certain way right and so that's
not it's not vivid but if i try to make
vivid
this experience of just okay i'm finally
going to experience free will i'm going
to notice my free will
right like it's got to be here
everyone's talking about it
where is it i'm going to pay attention
to i'm going to look for it and i'm
going to
i'm going to create a circumstance that
is is where
it has to be most robust right i'm not
rushed to make this decision
i'm not it's not a reflex i'm not under
pressure
i'm going to take as long as i want i'm
going to decide
it's not trivial like so it's not just
like reaching with my left hand to reach
with my right hand people don't like
those examples for some reason
let's make a big decision like
where should you know
what should my next podcast be on right
who do i invite on the next
podcast what is it like to make that
decision
when i pay attention there is no
evidence of free will
anywhere in sight it's like it doesn't
feel like it feels profoundly mysterious
to be to be going back between two
people you know like
is it going to be person a or person b
i've got all my reasons for a and all my
reasons why not and all my reasons for
be and
that there's some math going on there
that i that i'm not not even privy to
where certain concerns are trumping
others and
at a certain point i just decide and
yes you can say i'm the node in the
network that has made that decision
absolutely i'm not saying it's being
piped to me from elsewhere
but the feeling of what it's like to
make that decision
is
totally without a sense a
real sense of agency
because because something simply emerges
it's literally it's literally as tenuous
as
what's the next sound i'm going to hear
right or what's uh what's the next
thought that's going to appear
and it just something just appears you
know and
and if something appears to cancel that
something like if i say
i'm going to invite her and then i'm
about to send the email and i think oh
no
no i can't i can't do that there was a
thing in the
that new yorker article i read that i
got to talk to this guy
right that pivot at the last second you
can make it as
as muscular as you want
it always just comes out of the darkness
it's always mysterious
so right when you try to pin it down you
really can't ever find that
free will it's the the the the the
if you construct an experiment for
yourself and you're trying to really
find that moment when you're actually
making that
controlled author decision it's it's uh
and we're still we're still we know at
this point that if we were scanning your
brain
in some ex you know podcast guest
choosing experiment right we know at
this
point we would be privy to who you're
going going to pick before you are
you the conscious agent if we could
again this is operationally a little
hard to conduct but
there's enough data now to know that
something
very much like this cartoon is in fact
true
um and will ultimately be undeniable for
people
um they'll be able to do it on
themselves with their you know some app
um if you're deciding
what to you know where to go for dinner
or who to have on your podcast or
ultimately you know who to marry right
or what what city to move to right
like you you can make it as big or as
small a decision as you want
we could be scanning your brain in real
time and
at a point where you still think you're
uncommitted
we would be able to say with arbitrary
accuracy
all right lex is he's moving to austin
right i didn't choose that yeah he was
true it was it was going to be austin it
was going to be miami
he got he's catching one of these two
waves but
it's going to be austin and at a point
where you subjectively
if we if we could ask you you would say
oh no i'm still
i'm still working over here i'm still
thinking i'm still
choosing i'm still considering my
options and you've spoken to this
in you thinking about other stuff in the
world it's been very useful
to uh to step away from this illusion of
free will
and you argue that it's probably makes a
better world because you can be
compassionate and empathetic towards
others
and towards oneself
radically toward others in that
literally
hate makes no sense anymore i mean
there's certain things you can
really be worried about really want to
oppose really i mean
i'm not saying you'd never have to kill
another person like i mean self-defense
is still a thing right
but the idea that you're
ever confronting anything other than a
force of nature
in the end goes out the window right or
what does go out the window when you
really pay attention i'm not i'm not
saying that this
would be easy to under to grok if
you know you know someone kills a member
of your family i'm not saying you can
just
listen to my 90 minutes on free will and
you should be able to see that person as
identical to a
grizzly bear or or a virus
because it's so i mean we are so evolved
to uh deal with one another as
as fellow primates and as agents
but it's um yeah when you're talking
about the possibility of
you know christian you know truly
christian
forgiveness right it's like like
uh that as as testified to by you know
various
um uh
saints of that flavor over the over the
the
millennia yeah that is
that the doorway to that is to recognize
that no one really at bottom made
themselves
right and and therefore everyone what
we're seeing really
are differences in luck in the world
we're seeing people who are
very very lucky to have had good parents
and good genes and to be in good
societies and good opportunities
and to be intelligent and to be you know
not sociopathic
like it's none of it is on them they're
just reaping one lot the the fruits of
one lottery
after another and then showing up in the
world on that basis
um and then so it is with
you know every malevolent out
there right he he
or she didn't make themselves
even if that weren't possible
the utility for for self-compassion
is also enormous because it's when you
just look at what it's like
to regret
something or to feel shame about
something or feel deep embarrassment but
these states of mind are some of the
most
deranging experiences anyone has and and
they're reactive
the the kind of the the indelible
reaction
to them you know the memory of the thing
you said that you know the memory of the
wedding toast you gave
20 years ago that was just mortifying
right
the fact that that can still make you
hate yourself right and
like like that psychologically that is a
knot
that can be untied right speak for
yourself sam yeah
clearly you gave a great great toast it
was my toast that mortified
no no that's not what i was referring to
i i
i i'm deeply appreciative in the same
way that you're referring to of every
moment i'm alive
but i'm also powered by self-hate often
like several things in this conversation
already that i've spoken
i'll be thinking about like that was the
dumbest thing
you're sitting in front of sam harris he
said that
so like that but that somehow creates a
richer experience for me like i've
actually come to accept that as a nice
feature
of however my brain was built i don't
think i want to let go of that
well the thing you i think the thing you
want to let go of is
uh the suffering
associated with it so like so for me so
so
mr psychologically and ethically all of
this is very interesting
so i don't think we ever we should ever
get rid of things like
anger right so like hatred is hatred is
divorcible from anger
in the sense that hatred is this
enduring state
where you know whether you're hating
somebody else or hating yourself
it is just it is toxic and durable
and ultimately useless right like it
becomes it becomes self
nullifying right like you become less
capable as a person to solve any of your
problems it's not it's not instrumental
in solving the problem that is
that is is occasionally all this hatred
and anger for the most part isn't either
except
as a signal of salience that there's a
problem right so if somebody does
something that makes me angry
that just promotes this situation to to
conscious uh conscious attention in a
way that is stronger than
my not really caring about it right and
there are things that i think should
make us angry in the world
and they're the there's the behavior of
other people that should make us angry
because we should respond to it and so
it is with yourself if i do something
you know as a parent if i do something
stupid that harms
one of my daughters right
my belief my experience of myself and my
beliefs about free will
closed the door to my saying well i
should have done otherwise in the sense
that if i
could go back in time i would have
actually effectively done otherwise
no i would do given the same causes and
conditions i would do that thing
a trillion times in a row right but
you know regret and
feeling bad about an outcome are still
important
to capacities because like yeah you're
like i i desperately
want my daughters to be happy and
healthy so if i if i've done something
you know if i
if i crash the car when they're in the
car and they get injured right because
and i'm
i do it because i was trying to change
the song on my playlist or you know
something stupid
i'm going to feel like a total
how long do how long do i stew in that
feeling of regret right and
like what utility is there to extract
out of this error signal
and then what do i do we're always faced
with the question of what to do next
right and and how
to best do that thing that necessary
thing next
and how much well-being
can we experience while doing it like
how much
how miserable do you need to be to solve
your problems in life and to solve the
problems of
to help solve the problems of people
closest to you you know how
how miserable do you need to be to get
through your to-do list today
ultimately i think you can be
deeply happy
going through all of it right and not
and even navigating
moments that are scary
and you know really destabilizing to
ordinary people and
um i mean i think you know again
i'm i'm always up kind of at the edge of
my own capacities here and there
all kinds of things that stress me out
and worry me and i'm especially
something if it's
you're going to tell me it's something
with you know the health of one of my
kids you know it's very hard for me like
it's very hard for me to to be truly
equanimous around that
but equanimity is so useful
the moment you're in in response mode
right because
i mean the the the ordinary experience
for me
of responding to what seems like a
medical emergency for one of my kids
is to be obviously super
energized by concern to respond to that
emergency
but then once i'm responding all of my
fear
and agitation and worry and oh my god
what if this is really
something terrible but
finding any of those thoughts compelling
all that only diminishes my capacity
as a father to be good company while we
navigate
this really turbulent passage you know
as you're saying this actually one guy
comes to mind which is elon musk
one of the really impressive things to
me was to
observe how many dramatic things he has
to deal with throughout the day
at work but also if you look through his
life family too
yeah and how he's very much actually as
you're describing
basically a practitioner of this way of
thought which is
you're not in control you're basically
responding no matter how dramatic the
event and there's no reason to sort of
linger on the well yeah i think the
negative feelings are on that
well so i mean he but he's in a very
specific
situation which is which is unlike
normal life you know even his normal
life but normal life for for most people
because
when you just think of like you know
he's running so many businesses and he's
he's
they're very they're not they're
non-highly non-standard businesses
so what he's seen is everything that
gets to him
is some kind of emergency like it
wouldn't be getting to him if it needs
his attention
there's a fire somewhere so exactly so
he's constantly responding to
fires that have to be put out so
there's no default expectation that
there shouldn't be a fire
right but in our normal lives we live
most of it i mean most of us were lucky
right not everyone obviously on earth
but most of us who are at some kind of
cruising altitude
in terms of our lives where we're
reasonably healthy
and life is reasonably orderly and the
political apparatus around us is
reasonably functionable
functional functionable so i said
functionable for the first time in my
life through no free will of my own see
like i noticed those errors
and they do not feel like like like
agency
and nor does nor does the success of an
utterance feel like agency
he when you're when you're looking at
normal human
life right where you're you're just
trying to be happy
and healthy and get your work done
there's this default expectation that
there shouldn't be fires
people shouldn't be getting sick or
injured you know the
the we shouldn't be losing vast amounts
of our resources we should like
so when something really start like that
happens
people don't have a people don't have
that muscle
that they've like i've been responding
to emergency emergencies all day long
you know seven days a week in business
mode and so i have a very thick skin
this is just another one what it was i'm
not expecting anything else
when i wake up in the morning no we have
this default sense that
i mean honestly most of us have the
default sense that we
aren't going to die right or that we
should like maybe we're not going to die
right like death denial really is a
thing
you know we're we we're because and you
can see it
just like i can see when i reach for
this bottle
that i was expecting it to be solid
because when it isn't solid when it's a
hologram and i just
my fist closes on itself i'm
damn surprised people are damn surprised
to find out that they're going to die to
find out that they're sick to find out
that someone
that they love has died or is going to
die so it's like
the the fact that we are surprised by
any of that
shows us that we're we're living at a
we're living in a mode
that is um
you know we're perpetually diverting
ourselves from some
facts that should be obvious right and
and that
and the more the more salient we can
make them uh you know the more
i mean in the case of death it's a
matter of of being able to get one's
priorities straight i mean the
the moment again this is hard for
everybody even
those who are really in the business of
paying attention to it but
the moment you realize that every
circumstance is finite
right you've got a certain number of you
know you've got whatever whatever it is
8 000 days left in
a normal span of life and 8
000 is a sounds like a big number it's
not that big a number
right so it's just like and then you
then you can decide
how you want to go through life uh and
how you want to experience each one of
those days
and so i was back to where our jumping
off point
i would argue that you don't want to
feel
self-hatred ever i i would argue that
you don't want to
really uh
really grasp on to any of those moments
where you where you
are take or internalizing the fact that
you just made an error
you embarrassed yourself that something
didn't go the way you wanted it to
i think you want to you want to treat
all of those moments very very lightly
you want to extract
the the actionable information it's
something to learn oh
you know i i learned that when i
when i prepare in a certain way it works
better than i when i prepare in some
other way or don't prepare right like so
like yes
lesson learned you know and and do that
differently
but um
yeah i mean so many so many so many of
us have spent so much time with
a very uh
dysfunctional and hostile and even
hateful inner voice governing a lot of
our
self-talk and a lot of just just our
default way of being with ourselves i
mean the privacy of our own minds
we're in the company of of a real jerk
a lot of the time and um
and that that can't help but affect i
mean forget about just your
your own sense of well-being it can't
help but limit what you're capable of in
the world
with other people i'll have to really
think about that i just take pride that
my jerk
my inner voice jerk is much less of a
jerk than like somebody like david
goggins who's just like screaming in his
ear constantly so my
i just i have a relativist kind of
perspective that
it's not as bad as that at least well
having a sense of humor
also helps you know it's just like it's
not the stakes are
never quite what you think they are and
even when they are i mean
it's just the difference between see
being able to see the comedy of it
rather than because because
again there's this sort of dark star of
self-absorption
that pulls everything into it right and
it's like if if that that's the that's
the algorithm that's the algorithm you
don't
want to run so like it's like you just
want you just want things to be good so
like just push
push the concern out there like like the
like the not have the collapse of oh my
god what does this say about me
it's just like let's what does this say
about how do we make this
meal that we're all having together as
as uh
as fun as po and as useful as possible
and you're saying in terms of propulsion
systems you recommend
humor as a good spaceship to escape the
gravitational field of the
of that uh darkness well that certainly
helps yeah yeah
you